心の不安というテーマで今日のお話をさせていただきます
この不安という言葉が
なんかどこでもありそうな言葉ですけど
私もこの言葉 初めて日本語として聞いて
すぐ意味が何のことなく
こういうことかとわかりましたけど
不安に英語で何と言いますか
さっぱりわからないんです
英語だったら不安って何ですかね
え？ Afraid それは違うんですね
ご存知の方いらっしゃいますか？不安という英語の言葉
Anxiety  Anxiety
まあ そうですね そうですね
英語で言えばWorryという言葉はかなり近いと思います
で それなかなか英語の単語を思い浮かべないで
何を言ったらいいかわからなくなったんです
とにかく本当のところは
で なんでそういうことを申し上げたかというと
あまりにも日本的な言葉みたいに感じちゃうんですね
不安という言葉が で まあおっしゃる通りに
このWorryということは
Worriesと複数形使ってもいいし
で もう結構似ている言葉なんです
Anxietyはもうちょっと違いますけどね
まあ似てるんだけど それよりWORRYという W・O・R・R・Y が一番近いかもしれません
で あのパーリ語でもないんです
お経にも出てこないんです
不安という言葉が
ということはどういうことでしょうかね
だからすごい明確に心理学的なところです
あれほどもう 90%で心理学ですからね
お釈迦様の言葉っていうのは
それなのに不安という言葉に合うパーリ語の単語はない
そういうことは もしかすると当時の人々にとってはそんな不安というようなことはあまりなかったかもしれません
そんなに不安ということはなかったかもしれません
あったならば当然ね
言葉はあるんですからね
例えば英語でWORRYという言葉がありまして
それにも我々の言葉では言葉ないんです
よく英語であること Don’t worryという言葉ありますね
あれは自分の国の言葉で訳できないんです
ということはパーリ語でもないということなんです
実際にはないんです ですから
これはもしかすると インド文化の人々にない現象かもしれません
Worryという言葉がありますから
ヨーロッパ人にあるかもしれませんし
不安という日本語の言葉がありますから
日本文化にもあるかもしれません
不安という日本語の単語と
その同じ言葉は中国語で同じ意味を持っているかどうか
それはわからないんですね
だから もしかすると 1種の現代病
ではないかなと というふうに思われますね
この不安というもの もしかすると
これ 現代病ではないかと
不安でしょうがないということはよくありますからね
ということは 私にはあまりこの不安という言葉について
そんなに上手に権威を持って喋ることは不可能ということなんですね
だから 我々の文化ではないことだから
まああまりわからないかもしれませんし
ですから いくらか似ているところ
似ているところを まあお釈迦様の教えから考えて
現代訳に皆様に紹介したいと思います
で 本当に皆様味わっている実際の不安と
そういうものについて
話し終わってから皆様を集めてお互いにディスカッションして
どういうことかどういうことかとご理解した方がいいんです
で 私にはなかなか正直なところはね
まあそんなに厳密に理解しているわけじゃないんです
この現代人の不安ってどういうものかということは
ですから この まあ仏教の言葉に戻ると
他のいっぱい 他の似ている言葉がいっぱい出ているんですね
で 悩みという言葉あるし
苦しみという言葉あるし
燃えているという言葉あるし
燃えているというのは
この何かやりたくて この燃えているという日本語のポジティブ的な
燃えているという意味ではなくて
すごいネガティブ的にもう焼けているという意味で燃えているという言葉がありますし
内も外も人々はもうずっと燃えているんだと
あるいは混乱だらけですよと
内も外もという言葉はあるんですね
混乱という場合は この内の混乱というのは
心の中でぐちゃぐちゃ状態と
外の混乱というのは 外の社会の関係でぐちゃぐちゃになっていると
そういう言葉いろいろ別々にあるんですね
それで心の状態の場合も
悩みの状態 なんかどうしようかというふうに
何ですか ため息している心の状態とか
なんか悔しくてもうたまらない状態とかね
それからもうどうしようもなくて
何もこの あまりにも悔しいというか
苦しいというか 失望感でどうにもならない状態に
いわゆる機能を失った状態
心の 徹底的に落ち込んだ状態とか
そういう言葉はございます
どれほど心の状態に言葉あるかというと
日本語訳できない
昨日の勉強会でも 辞書を引ながらみんなに聞いたんだけど
全然 現代我々に通じる言葉はないんですね
いわゆる心に本当にある状態なんですけど
日本語の言葉がない 辞書を引くとちゃんと何か言葉あるんですよ
パーリと日本語辞書を引くと
そういうのは仏教用語であって
強引に 中国の中国語の漢字を当てているだけ
それを理解するためには
漢字について大変なじみがあって
その文化の中で理解する人でないと理解できない
ですから 一般の方々に仏教専門用語をばらまいても
あまり心に響く意味はないんですね
ですから 仏教用語 仏教というのは
やはり心に響く 心に一番近い言葉でしゃべらなくちゃいけない
そうすると生きているんです
ですから パーリ語のパーリ経典に出てくる心の状態
たくさんあるんだけど
それはなかなか日本語訳できない
日本語でふさわしい言葉がない
それで日本語である不安という言葉にピッタリ合うパーリ語の言葉がない
なんかどこかでずれてるんでしょうね
考え方が そこら辺
合うことはなかなか合わせるようにするのは結構難しい仕事なんです
で これだけは言えるんです
経典で出てくるいろんな心の状態
それに日本語の単語がないということは
そういう状態について日本文化ではあまり気にしていない
大した問題として扱っていない
あるいは未だにその問題は特別に
何て言いますか 他の問題から特別に取り出して見出してないということ
そこで不安という言葉はなんでパーリ経典でないかというと
もしかすると現代我々が味わっている不安という精神的な状態は当時でなかった
あるいはその状態はある
基本的な状態ではなくて
いろんな状態 いろんな心の状態をまとめて言っている総合名詞かもしれません
コレクティブナウンかもしれません
あまり仏教ではコレクティブナウン使わないんです
なぜならばコレクティブナウンじゃなくて
この一つ一つ別々に取ったら
その原因わかりますから
いわゆる大雑把なことかもしれません
不安というのは 大雑把な言葉にはパーリ語でそれほど単語はないんです
きちんと厳密に喋るということはありますから
そういうことだろうと思います
ですから話に戻りますけど
大体 日本 一般的に言えば
何か不安でもありますかと言えば
結構みんないろいろ不安ありますよと言うんです
不安がありますと そこで私に言われたら
私はすぐ聞く質問は 何に不安がありますかと
具体的に知らなきゃ僕には理解できないんです
そこで相手方はどうしても機嫌が悪くなるんです
馬鹿にされているんだと
親切に教えてくれないんだと
せっかく自分の悩んでいるんだから
せっかく宗教の人に聞いているのにというふうな態度を取るんです
僕はそれは気にしない
徹底的に あなたは何に不安がありますかと
具体的に言ってください
具体的に言ってもらわなきゃ
僕には何のお手伝いもできませんと
ですから 我々もただ単に大雑把で漠然として不安不安ではなくて
何に不安がありますかと
具体的に自分の状態を見た方が
問題が出てくるかもしれません
英語のことわざに猫が袋から出るということわざがあるんですね
だからいわゆる問題はもう出たということ
意味なんですね
そういうふうに
あ こういうことだと出てくるかもしれません
一つ 私は何に不安かと聞いたところで
なかなか答えてくれなかった時もありましたし
具体的に
だからもしかすると本人もただ単に不安不安と言うだけで
結局なんだかわかってないんじゃないかなと
その場合 私はもういい加減にしろと
具体的に知らないことには
もちろん具体的に答えるわけにもいきませんし
まあわかりやすいことは
私は不安だと思いますということなんですね
その場合は それだったら私の答えは
じゃああなたは不安ではないと私は思います
終了 終わりですと
だから 我々人間持っている精神的な問題の一番の解決法というのは
きちんと明確にしてもらう
しないことなんですね
はっきりとこれは問題だと
はっきりとこれは問題だと取ってみたら
すぐそこに答えもあるんです
あるいは あ なんてことない
こんなことに不安があったかと
なんか馬鹿馬鹿らしくなって
それで消えてしまうんですね
一応そういうものだから
覚えておいてください
今 例えば何か問題があったら
もう悩むんじゃなくて
問題は何ですか？と
なぜこのことについて悩んでるんですか？と
ものすごい具体的に見ると
それも見えてくるんですね
見えたらもう問題終わりなんですよ
解決なんです わかればそれで終わりなんです
それがすごい便利なとこなんですよ
何か大変なことをしなくちゃいけないとか
それはないんです わかればもう終わり
問題は　理解できれば 特に心の問題の場合はすごく便利なところで
そういうとこなんです
体の問題の場合はそこまで便利じゃないんですね
自分の体の問題 わかったんだからといって終わるわけじゃないんです
それなりに薬飲んだり
運動したり 食べ物を食べたりとか
何かやらなくちゃいけないんですね
体は物質ですからね 心はもう大変便利なもので
わかっちゃえば
もうそれでその問題終わりと
そういうことをまず理解しておいておきましょう
それでこの解決方法とか
特別な講義なくても これで物は済みますよ
心の不安をなくす方法とかね
特別にまた 2時間ぐらい喋る必要ないんです
具体的にこれで悩んでるんだと自分で考えてみたら
あ なるほど これで悩んでるんだとわかったら
それ消えてしまう
じゃあそれはそうなんですけど
とにかく一般的に大雑把に人に聞けば
どんな人も不安があるんだということは言ってるんです
この大雑把な不安はどうやって生まれるかというところは
まあ順番に説明いたします
この不安というのは
私は感じた限りは みんなこの将来に対する不安なんですね
それ 正しいかどうか分からない
私は感じた限りでは 不安というのは
将来に対して生まれるものなんです
過去に対して不安が生まれるということはないだろうと思います
だから不安で悩んでいるのは私ではないんだから
皆さんはあまり悩んでないと思いますけど
一般的な社会ではよく悩んでるし
ですからわかりませんけど
もしかすると過去に対したことについて不安で悩んでいる人よりは
この将来に対していろいろ不安があるというのは事実かもしれません
私は感じたところで
将来に対してなぜ不安があるかというと
これからどうなることかとわからないんですね
だから不安なんです 落ち着きがないと
この落ち着きがないというと
言葉あるんですよ 英語でも
アンレストという言葉があるんです
そういうのは我々の言葉でもあります
パーリ語でも あるんです
直訳する言葉はないんだけど
似てる言葉があるんです
アンレストといえば いわゆる落ち着きがない
心が落ち着かないと
もしかすると不安というのはそういうものですけどね
具体的に言えば 不安不安というよりは
心は何かどこかで落ち着きがないと
それをごまかして不安と言うんです
とにかく将来に対してどうなるかわからないんだから
不安が生まれる あるいは心が落ち着かなくなっちゃう
ほっとすることはできなくなる
それは不安でしょうと思います
じゃあそれだったら 将来のこと
未来のことを徹底的に確実なものにした方が
不安が消えるでしょ
将来ということは これから自分の人生ということは
ものすごく 確固たるものにしてしまう
固定化する
そうすると不安が消えると単純計算で出てくるんですね
明日どうなるかわからないということは不安でありますから
明日はこうなります 明後日はこうなりますと
もう来年はこうなります
再来年はこうなりますと
そういうふうに きちんとした決まっている 固定した
システムが作れば不安が消えると
それで社会を見ると この社会はどんどん発展しているとみんな威張ってるんですね
私は全くすごいケチをつけて違う言葉を知っているんだからね
発展してない 変化しているだけですっていうのは私の言葉ですけど
威張るなと 何が発展しているんですかと
ただ変化しているだけではないかとか
ただ変わっているだけではないかと
まあ その話は置いておいて
人間っていうのは自分たちが発展していると思っているんです
とにかく発展しようと
この発展する この行動の衝動というか
裏にあるエネルギーは不安をなくそうということなんです
その方向で考えると それだったら昔の人々にも不安があっただろうと思えるんですね
なぜならば 社会発展しようという努力が昔からありましたからね
でもちょっと違うところもありますよ
昔 歴史を見ると この発展しようではなくても
一般人にはそんなに関係なかったんですよ
この国の王とか そんな正真正銘のくだらない頭の悪い連中が不安で
とにかく自分の国をきちんとしなくちゃいけないんだと
もっと広げなくちゃいけないんだと
国を巨大帝国を作らなくちゃいけないんだと思って
戦争ばっかりなんですね
昔の歴史っていうのは
戦争するのは一般人じゃないでしょうに
一般人が巻き込まれるだけで
これ政治家やってるんですね
当時の政治家っていうのは
独裁者で王でしたからね
王か帝王か まあどっちか
その人々には不安があったんですね
自分の国をもし誰かに取られたらどうするんですかと
国民が自分に対して反乱を起こしちゃったらどうするんですかと
自分の豊かさと権力をなくなったらどうしようかとビクビクして生活していたんですね
それで落ち着きがなくなっちゃって
とにかく抑えなくちゃいけないんだと
国民も抑えなくちゃいけないと思って
みんな抑えてしまう 独裁的に すごく抑えてしまう
それでたまたま止まらないで
隣の国までやっつけてやると
それでずっと戦争していたんですね
現代時代に来るまで
人間の歴史っていうのは戦争の歴史なんですね
それは事実ですよ
ですから過去世で不安があったのは
この王様みたいな連中なんですね
ですから 現代人みんなに不安があるということは
みんなもう帝王様みたいにも王様みたいな状態になったということなんでしょう
だから僕はあまり 言わないんだけど
一つ 王様たちにちょっと形容詞使ったんですね
昔の王様たちはどんなもんかと
何者かと その形容詞はもしかすると現代人に合うかもしれません
だから 王っていうのはわがままで
自分の権力のことしか考えない
自分が選ばれた大馬鹿もんだと思っているし
選ばれた人間だと 人は自分に支配されているのは当たり前だと
人を搾取するのは当たり前ではないかと
国の豊かさ 財産やら全部一人占めにして食べて遊んで生活するのは
これは当たり前のことだと
一般人が苦しんだってそんなの関係ないんだと
でも一般人があまりにも苦しんで税金が入らないと
これ心配だ 何とかしなくちゃとするだけであって
良い王っていうのはほとんどいなかったんです
それで歴史家を書いた人々もものすごく
とんでもない連中で
とにかく歴代王様をものすごく応援して応援して
こういう偉大なる王がいて
こういう風な戦争で この戦争はこうやって勝ちました
あの戦争はああやって勝ちましたとかね
国土はこれぐらい広げたんですか？とかね
またそこにこういうこういう問題で
この国はこうやって壊れてしまったとか
またそこにこういう人が現れたとか
そんな話ばっかりで
だから過去を知るのは本当に人間には役に立ちますけど
ある面で見ると 歴史なんか勉強って何の役にも立たないんで
嘘ばっかり聞いてるんだから
人の話何もないんだから
王様のいいところしか書いてないんだから
悪いところ書いてないんだから
もうちょっと敏感に読むとよく見えるんですよ
わがままで高慢で 自分勝手で
とにかく自分の権力だけ
きっちりと決めればいいということで行動していたんですね
そういう人々には不安があったんです
現代人にも不安があるということは
もうそこで全く同じ現象じゃないんだけど
やっぱり民主主義が発展して
一人一人の人がそれなりの権力と自由を持つようになったんです
いわゆる自分の王は自分になったんですね
現代社会では自分のことを自分でしなくちゃいけない
自分の命は自分で守らなくちゃいけない
自分の食べる分は自分で探さなくちゃいけない
自分の安全は自分で守らなくちゃいけない
他の人はいちいち言わない
ああしろこうしろという権利はない
人に他人に迷惑をかけてはいけない
人にはプライバシーというものがある
ということに この民主主義というかね
デモクラシーの場合はそうなってきたんです
王はいない
いわゆるすごい巨大な偉い人はいない
みんなそれなりに平等で同じだと
ですから 立場は違うんだけど
今はすべての人は自分の王様は自分になっている
だから当然ながら不安っていうものは出てくる
じゃないかなと
ですから本当にすごく不安になるんですよ
全部自分でやらなくちゃいけないんだから
それでうまくいくかいかないか
まだわからないんですね
例えばよく聞こえることは
具体的に言ってくれと言ったら
ある人はこう言ったんですね
体 自分の病気のこと心配で不安ですよと
そう言ったら 今あなた病気
何か病気ありますか？と
今は何もないんだけど
やっぱりその時も自分が病気になったら
自分で何とかしなくちゃいけないんですね
他の社会が来て 大丈夫
あなた病気になったって全部やってくれるんだから
もう心配するな そんなことはと親切に言ってくれる社会がいません
奥さんが病気になっても
旦那さんが仕事に行っちゃうんです
誰もそばにいてくれないんですね
だから不安なんですね
そういうことで不安という現象はあるんじゃないかなと
ですから この解決法なんですけど
そんなに自分の抵抗になるのは
やめたらどうですかね
私はもう独立して生きている
私は私の主人だよと 私は私の王だよという
その現代民主主義から我々得ている
この生き方 ちょっと置いておいた方がいいんじゃないんですかね
もうちょっとこの我々の高慢というかね
頑固さね もう本当に昔の王と同じなんですよ
すごい頑固なんですね
すごい高慢なんですね
だからこういう話でも
いつでもおだてておだてて
一般公の講演をする時でも喋らなくちゃいけないんですよ
ありとあらゆる敬語を使って
聞いている人はもうとことん褒めて
おだてておだてて
それにもう決まってるんです
私はやりませんけど
どうせ常識外れてるんだから
別に気にしないし
で それぐらいこの人々っていうのは 高慢なんですね
で 人を馬鹿にするのは決していけないことなんですけど
そういう言葉を言ってるわけじゃなくて
やっぱり何かものを知っている人は
ちょっと叱って言ってもいいんじゃないんですかね
あんたいい加減にしろとね
言った方がいいんじゃないんですかね
そんなことやめなさいと
それは経験がある人が
年上の人が まあ自分より何か知っている人が
厳しくちょっと叱ってやるとかね
厳しく教えてやるとかね
それぐらい他人に対しても責任感を持つということはいいんじゃないかなと思いますよ
あまりにも厳密に民主主義になっちゃうと
関係ないんだと 俺には関係ないんだという感じでしょ
無関心で
自分一人で王様で
だから喋る時も国王たちに喋ってるんだから
もうとことんおだてて喋らなくちゃいけないということは
誰にでもあまり まあ聞いてもいいし
聞かなくてもいいし 実行してもいいし
実行しなくてもいいし
本人が自分だけのことしか心配してないんだから
自分に人気さえあればいいんです
喋る人には すごい講演でしたと
ものすごい面白かったと
楽しくてしょうがなかったと
聴講したお客様からもう声援いただければ
それでも OK と 素晴らしいと
その場合も見えるのはもう自分だけ良ければいいという考え方なんですね
ですから この社会に不安という現象は
私は現代病と言ったんだけど
確実に現代病であって
民主主義っていうのは現代的な社会でしたから
社会ですから まああるもので
だからそれ直せるかどうか分かりませんけど
もうちょっと人のことに対しても
ちょっと責任持てるような
ありがたい先輩たちがいた方がいいと思いますよ
世の中で今 親は親でなくなったし
父親は父親でなくなったし
息子が父親にこの野郎という状態になったし
あまりにも平等になりすぎなんですね
それはあまりそんなにいいということはないでしょうに
人間というのは指導してもらって
教えてもらって成長するのはごく普通な法則だと思いますけどね
生まれつき国王が生まれるわけじゃないし
生まれるはもうただのバカな赤ちゃんだから
それはもう教育させなくちゃいけないんだから
教育によって王になるか泥棒になるかということはそこで決められますから
ですから 真理から見れば
人間には 何といいますか
教育ということは必要なんですね
指導してもらう リードしてもらう
教えてもらうということは人間に必要なんですけど
それと この一人一人はもうとことんありがたくて平等で偉いという概念が出てきて
それあまりにもやりすぎて
人に大きな御世話です
教えてあげるのということまで言っちゃって
誰も厳しく教えたりはしない
心配しない ですから 自分のことを誰も心配してくれないんだから
もう自分が自分のことを心配で心配でたまらないんです
何もわからないんだから
誰も教えてくれないんだから
会社に至ってもいい加減で教えてくれるんだから
新しく入った人はどうすればいいかわからないんですね
親切に愛情を持って厳しく教えるということはないんです
学校に行っても同じこと
だから我々現代人というのはどうすればいいかということをわからない
失敗したら叱られるし
追い出されるし だから失敗してはいけないし
それだったら正しいやり方を教えてくれと言ったら教えてくれる人がいないし
そういうことで もうどうしようもない問題なんですね
この 不安という問題が
まあ そこまではこのイントロダクションで
一応不安というのはそういうどういうものかということは
大体そんな内容なんですね
話は イントロダクションを理解しておけばそれで終わりですけど
別にいちいち 一つひとつ項目で説明しなくても
仏教の似ている話に話してみると
生命の法則とか宇宙の法則
そういうところから話してほしいということがありますけど
そこから話すぐらいは私には能力はありませんが
できるだけのことは考えてみます
仏教から見ると 仏教では 無常論ということがあるんです
無常論とは言わないんだけど
一切は無常であるという言葉があるんですね
で 一切は無常であるというと
まあ何でも入るんですよ
すべての現象が無常であると
そこに物質的な現象も入るし
精神的な心の世界も入るんですね
無常っていうのは安定していないということなんですね
法則として
無常ってそういうことなの
安定していない
変化していくんだと
そこで宇宙を見ても不安定な状態であるということは
我々は知っている で 宇宙は必死になって安定しようと努力する
でも 安定は永遠に成り立たないんです
で なんで地球が自転していますかというと
エネルギーはバランス取ってないんですね
だからもう限りなく回ってしまっちゃう
そこで地球に引っ張られているんだ
太陽に引っ張られているんだから
また太陽周りにも行かなくちゃいけない
太陽が安定しているかというと
それもまたそうじゃないし
それも中身も同じでずっと変化していっちゃうし
自分の体力はものすごい恐ろしい速さで失っていくしね
太陽が エネルギーは外に出ていっちゃうんですよ
で 他の星にまた影響を受けて引っ張られて
他のところ回ってるんですよ 自分も
そこは終わりがないんですね
回ったり回ったり 変化したり
回ったり 変化したりする
だからどんな状態に変化しても
これは安定という状態は宇宙法則ではないんです
人間がこの宇宙のことを考えちゃうと
どんなことを考えちゃうと
この特に無常ということを考えると
我々はこう思っちゃうんですね
あるものがあると そのあるものが無常だから変化しましたと
違うものになったと だからある立場から
考えちゃうんです 例えば
花が咲いている状態は基本的な状態にとったら
花が枯れた状態は無常なんですね
蕾の状態は基本的に考えると
花が咲いたその蕾の無常なんですね
ですから 我々が ある一つの立場を根底にして
そこから無常を考えようとしているんです
例えば 人が歳取ってるのを見て
ああ やっぱり無常だと思って
そうは思わないんだけど みんな
思ったならば じゃあどんな立場から考えているんですか？って
もしかしたらその人の若くて美しくて光り輝いていた年を中心に考えて
その年を土台として考えて
やっぱり無常だと思っちゃう
じゃあそれだったら  20歳の若者を見たら無常だと言えるでしょう？
その若者の小さい時代ね
小学生時代とか中学生時代を中心に考えちゃうと
今 20歳のでっかな大人だから
可愛くもないんだから
子供と比べると ああ 無常やと思えるんですよ
でも人間っていうのは不思議なことで
20歳の人を見て無常だと思わない
子供なんか見て無常だと思わない
これ  40歳取って 50歳ぐらいになっちゃうと
まあ 50  60になってくると
やっぱりその時初めてやっぱり無常だと気がつくんです
そんないい加減な無常はちょっとね
困るでしょ 都合のいい無常
で そこは人間の無常に対する考え方の間違いという間違いなんですね
ある状態は安定している状態だと
まずもう前提として決めておく
決めて そこから物事を考えちゃうと
この尺度から無常だと
それでその尺度にまだ至ってないものに対してすごく希望をして
もう楽しみに待ってるんです
だから 例えば若くて元気でいる状態は
人生の中心と考えちゃうと
子供たちを見たら 子供たちに対してすごい希望いっぱいで楽しみに見ているんですよ
変化してくれるまで この状態まで
それでその状態過ぎ去っていくと
悲しみに見ているというか
だから一人の人の 自分の一人の人のことそうできません
社会を見てそういうことなんですよ
社会人というのは 我々というのは子供を見るともうすごく楽しいんです
よく元気に早く大きくなって
もうという感じで 希望溢れて楽しみに希望で見ていて
年取っている人々を見ると
ああ かわいそうだと 病気で体が弱くてとかね
それはこの若さ中心に考えているからなんです
ですから 僕はここでちょっとした文句を言いたいんですよ
ある状態中心に安定した状態と思って考えちゃうと
無常に 2つのアティチュード
2つの態度が出てくるんですよ
一つはこの安定した状態から変化するのは嫌と
安定する状態へ変化するのは OK だと
楽しみだと
ですから 子供は成長するのはすごい楽しみで
大人が成長するのはすごい悲しみで
でしょ でも同じ無常なんですよ
同じ変化の流れなんです
だから ある無常には OK サインと
ある無常にはもうストップサインと出したがっちゃいますけど
そんないい加減なことできるわけないでしょうに
法則に対しては
だから我々の態度がなんかすごいバカバカらしいというか
バカバカらしいんですよ
そういう態度で人生全部設計しているんです
だから誰一人も もう合理的に無常を見ていない
そこで宇宙のことなんですけど
今現代 我々生きている宇宙を見て
これは安定している状態だと思っちゃう
思って 地球の過去を考えちゃう
地球の過去を考えちゃうと
すごい恐ろしかったと
ものすごく暑くてとかね
なんとか時代 なんとか時代とかあったりしてとかね
今から 45億年前でもうやっと生命は誕生しましたとかね
今なんか今の状態はすごい万々歳の状態で考えているんですね
バカバカしくて聞いていられないんだけど
そこで現代人がもう近い将来地球は破滅しますよと言って
とんでもない 不安作って慌てているんですね
バカもいいところなんですよ
それは今の状態は地球の最高な正しい安定した状態であるならば
これから変化するのは怖いし
これまでの変化はもうありがたいということになっちゃいますけど
でも同じ過程だからどうでもいいんじゃないかと私は聞きたいんですよ
これから地球はどうなろうとも
まあそれはどうでもいいんじゃないかと
ですから この無常の考え方で我々が間違っているところは何ですか？と聞くと
ある一つの状態をこの基準にすることなんですね
自分に対しても 自分何々さんというと
心の中で大雑把ですけど
それは僕みたいな意地悪の人がとことん質問すると出ちゃいますからね 外へ
ある年の状態 自分という基準にしているんです
例えば田中さんという人がいるならば
私は田中ですよというと
無意識の中で田中というイメージがあるんですよ
そのイメージにはちゃんとした年齢があって
それなりの体力やら能力やらいろいろあって
ある一つ基準があるんですね
それと比べて そこまで至った道は楽しみで
その状態から行った道が悲しみで考えているんです
ですから みんなに聞いてください
昔はどうですか？昔は楽しかった
良かったとか バカなこと言うでしょ
それでちょっと年も取って
いろいろ問題が社会問題やら家族問題があったら
今は大変だよと それは今は大変だよという人の基準がもう過ぎ去っているんですよ
私という基準が
そこでその基準にいる人
実際の年齢とこの基準年齢はぴったし合う人々いるんですね
その人々は別に何のことなく
いい加減ふざけてもう明るく生活しているんです
でもあまり長持ちはしない
この 1年  2年経つと 実際の年齢は経っていっちゃうし
この基準年齢はそのままで変化しないものだから
安定したものだから それで人生苦しいと感じ始めちゃうんですね
ああ 嫌だ 嫌だとかね
それわからないんだったら具体的な例を申しますけど
例えば若者は結婚するとかね
その時代では誰にも文句はない
どんな問題でも自分で何とかするとかね
すごい元気で頑張っちゃうとか
それで結婚して 1年  2年経っちゃうと
どんどんどんどんつぶつぶと いろいろ文句が出てくるんですよ
あれは良くない これは良くない
あれはいけない これはいけないとかね
それでどんどんいっちゃうと
もう文句ばっかしの人生になっちゃうと
だからそういうシステムがありまして
で わかるでしょ？そのシステムはすごくバカらしいと
我々の考えているシステムは
だから解決法というのは基準を捨てることなんです
基準がないんだと
ですから
そうすると いつでも今の状態にいる
自分の私は田中ですよという場合は
実際の年齢で生きている自分が田中であるということは
認める状態になれば もう何のこともないんです
すべての不安が消えるはずなんです
だからなぜ宇宙法則はなんとか関係あるかと考えちゃうと
宇宙を見ると星なんかの寿命見ると
すごい長い間ね 生きていて消えていっちゃう
空を見るとね もう数えられないほどの星があって
生まれている星もあるし
今はすでにもう何万年前も死んだ星なんですけど
いまだに我々に見えると
もうそこに星がいませんけど
もう死んでいるんです
それでも我々にはそこに星があるように見える
それぐらい遠いところに
だからそういう基準で地球のことを考えちゃうと
何のことないでしょうに
地球は生まれてそんな時間も経ってないし
またそんなに時間経たないうちに消えちゃうしね
星一つの寿命もないでしょうに地球には
だから宇宙についても基準は作られないんです
科学者が言うことが正しければ
ビッグバンということがあって
それは宇宙の始まりだと偉そうなことを言うんだけど
基準を作りたがっちゃうんですね科学者でも
そこからはスタートですよと
で そこでいろいろ変化あったりして
でも最終的にそんなにね
もう広げて広げて
キリがなく広げるわけにはいきませんし
どこかで消えなくちゃいけないんですね
本当に広げていくならば
この物質は全部消えていくんですよ
今 物体と物体だけ広げるだけのことなんですけど
どんどん広げて 物体そのものも壊れて広げていかなくちゃいけない
ですから 最終的にはその原子まで全部壊れなくちゃいけない
で 壊れて素粒子みたいなエネルギー状態にならなくちゃいけない
あるいは真空状態にならなくちゃいけない
で そこで終わりますか？と
そこで終わらない 真空状態からまたエネルギーを
エネルギーは出し始めて
素粒子がエネルギー出し始めて
またどんどん広げて また
物質が表れてきて また宇宙が現れてきてとかね
そこは人間には想像できる時間の
時間ではないんですね
だから宇宙の無常っていうのはそういうもので
そういうのは放っておくしか人間には何の方法もないんです
だから 我々に関係あるのは
そういう あるのは
基準を作ることはいかにバカバカらしいかということなんですね
我々 このお世話になっているお天道様が
まあ一応そんなに歳はないんですね
生まれてそんなに時間経ったわけじゃないし
まあいくらか若い方ですけどね
それよりかなり先輩の星たちいっぱい宇宙にあるし
そういうところでどういう変化が起こるか我々わからないし
仏教ではもうありとあらゆる宇宙の中で生命がいるんだと
言ってるんです 昔から
この太陽の周りだけじゃないんだと
もうすごいたくさん もう広くて
まあどこ向いたってもいることはいるんだと
あんまり真剣に考えてないんです そこら辺は
今我々には何かエイリアンなんかいると思っちゃったら
それすごいニュースなんですけどね
驚いたりするし
昔いろいろあったんですね 話とかね エイリアンという現代的な映画もありますけどね
映画作るところまで驚くべき話なんですね
それは人間基準に考えているんだから
この地球に神様に創られた人間こそ生命であると
人間こそ優れている素晴らしい生命ですよと
という基準で考えちゃうと
エイリアンという映画は作られるんですよ
あるいは ものすごい人間より能力あるエイリアンがいたりとか
人間破滅しようと破壊しようとしてくるエイリアンのこととか
いくらでも妄想はできるんです
だから ああいう映画では
若者に 現代子どもたちに言っているメッセージは
徹底的に悪のメッセージなんですよ
見ない方がとってもいいんですよ 道徳的には
SF映画とかね
ああいうのは道徳的に見ていけない映画なんですよ
大人しか見てはいけない映画とか
子供に禁じられてるんだけど
自然的なものなんですけど
だからそんなものよりは
ああいう 頭に変な概念を入れちゃう
人間こそありがたい
その中でもアメリカ人だけ素晴らしいんだとかね
なんとかとかいうのは
その差別的な概念があって
人間のヒーローがいて
エイリアンみんなやっつけてしまって
勝ったというふうな
すごい品格のない
汚いレベルの低いメッセージでしょ
それだったら子供たちにアダルトオンリーという映画を見せた方がいいんです
頭ちょっと混乱するかもしれませんけど
ちょっとしちゃうと何のこともないと
不自然だとわかりますから
人間っていうのは 子供たちをちゃんと守ってほしいんですよ
だから生命に対する愛情とか
我々もそんなに偉大なるあーだこーだではなくてね
ただこの宇宙で生きている存在ですよと
ですから ほどほどに
相手のこともそれなりに考えて生きるべきですよというメッセージなんですね必要なのは
それはないんです
暴力ばっかしでね ヒーローばっかしで
だからいろいろ精神的な病気の人々も出てくるし
まあとにかく 宇宙のスケールで物事を考えちゃうと
基準を作ることの愚かさということは見えるかもしれません
その中でも人間というのはせいぜい 100年しか生きていませんから
生命誕生も 40 億年前だから
人間が現れてきて ほんのちょっと前でしょうに
我々の現代科学文明っていうのはもう 200 年も経ってないんだから
400年になるとどうなるかと またわからないし
こんな速さで変化するかどうかまたわからないし
だから基準を作らなきゃ問題は消える
そこで無常という仏教の言葉から出てくる
いろいろ考え方あるんですよ
無常 もう一つ 私が言う言葉というのは流れという言葉なんですね
英語でこれフラックスというんです
流れなんですね
その流れとして考えちゃうと
宇宙みたいにのんびり変化するものじゃないんです
かなり強烈な速さで物質も心も変化するんです
アインシュタインとかね
なんとかとか いろいろ物質として存在する場合はどれぐらいのスピードですかということはもう考えてるんだからね
例えば光と同じ速度になっちゃったら
それは物体は物体として存在しないんだと
その相対論というのはもうすごく合ってる相対論なんですね
今ここで物体でいても
我々もやっぱり光の速度でずっと我々の体変化していくんですよ
それは見えないのは基準があるんだから
例えば細胞基準で考えちゃうと
光の速度で変化しているということはわからなくなっちゃうんです
細胞が生まれて死ぬまでは 3ヶ月間ぐらいかかりますから
でも人間が 3ヶ月間で新しく生まれ変わったと誰も認めてないんですよ
私は 100 年も生きてますよと頑張っちゃうんですね
100年生きていられないんですよ
細胞基準で考えちゃうと
3ヶ月間ですね せいぜい
それで新しい人なんです
新しい人だから 新しい考え方と全部新しいなんですけど
だから都合のいいところで基準使って作ってるんだからね
ですから この細胞のレベルで考えちゃうと
私達はもう 3ヶ月間の速さで完璧に変化して新しいものになっちゃうし
じゃあ原子の分子のレベルで考えちゃうと
もっと早いでしょうに
いわゆる細胞 1個もずっと外からいろんな分子をもらって
持って中にあるものは取り出し
捨てて入れ替えているでしょうに
ですから 細胞 1個も生まれて死ぬまではもうずっと新しいものになっているんですよ
やがて細胞の形でいられなくなっちゃったら壊れると
それだけ その前 いろんなものすごい速さで
分子のレベルで考えちゃうと変化していくんですね
それをもっと小さくして
原子のレベルで考えちゃうと
もっと早く変化する 素粒子のレベルで考えちゃうと
強烈な速さで変化しているんですね
だからこの体は結局素粒子の塊でもあるんですね
細胞の塊でもあるし でももっと分かりやすく素粒子の塊なんですね
でもここに素粒子っていうのは 1箇所に固まるわけじゃないんです
ずっと変化していくんです
そこは体の変化で
心っていうのは命というもので
生命ということは心というし
認識する ここに私がいると
これ変な認識なんですけど
認識は正しくしているわけじゃないんだけど
ここに私がいるという認識があるんです
それに心というんです
霊魂なんかあるわけじゃないんです
ここに私がいると認識する
ほとんど何を認識するかというと
この物質を認識しているんです
それはいい加減で認識しているんですよ
本物じゃなくて 目で見るのはほとんど幻覚で
耳で聞くのはほとんど幻覚で
まあほとんどではなくて
全部幻覚で
実際に真理の状態で認識するということはない
私がいる 私がいると
どこで何が私ですか？と
具体的に言ってくれと言ったら言えないんでしょうに
でも私がいるんだよというだけであって
その私がいるんだよと認識する働きに
我々は生命 心というんです
それに仏教では霊魂 魂という言葉を使わないのは
それもまた人間の 使ってもいいんです別に
霊魂 魂 精神 心 生命
どんな言葉でも好き勝手に使っても構いませんけど
霊魂 魂 なんとか言っちゃうと
なんか誤解しちゃうんですね
いわゆる認識する主体があって
それはどこかでじーっと止まっていて
変化しないで変化しているものを見ているんだというふうな
と思うだけであるならば証拠欲しいんです
ですから 仏教から見ると証拠はあるのは
私たちはずっといろんなものを認識する
物体より早く認識するものは変化する
だから私の言葉を聞くたびに
皆様の心がそれを認識して
心が変わってしまうんです
楽しくなったり もう怒ったり
つまらなくなったり いろいろ感情が生まれて変化してしまうんです
だから 耳に音が入った瞬間で
それを聞いて 心が変化して新しい心が生まれてしまう
そういうふうに我々は怒ったり
笑ったり 泣いたり 考えたり
眠くなったり つまらなくなったり
落ち込んだり 舞い上がったり
いろいろ心の変化は瞬間瞬間あります
強烈な速さで心は変化していく
だから心にも基準がないんです
これは私ですよというふうに思う
その心がないんです たまたま今
私が怒っているだけで
次の瞬間で楽しがっているし
次の瞬間で泣いているし
次の瞬間でまた違う感情があるし
そこに私はという心の基準またないんです
だから間違っているのは
我々はそこで基準を作ったことで
私はという何かあるように感じちゃうと
そこからすべての不安が生まれてくるんです
基本的な論理ですが
論理的な ちょっと難しいんですけどね
仏教の論理は難しいんです
ですから 仏教をやめるか
頑張って勉強するか どっちか
道がないんです
こちらでは優しくするわけにはいきません
嘘を言ってはいけないんだから
よく頼まれるんですよ
嘘を言ってくださいと
僕はまあそれほど怒ることはないんです
人の機嫌を取って このバカどもが理解できるようにとかね
ちゃんと言ってくる
それはもう本人がわかってないだけで
嘘を言ってくれと頼まれることだからね
なんで私は別に私の兄弟でもない
子供でもないし 誰でもない人々の前で嘘を言って地獄に落ちなくちゃいけないんですかね
そこまでバカじゃないんです
誰かの人気がなかったとか
だからといって私は地獄に落ちる必要ないでしょうに 嘘を言って
昨日インターネットであるお寺のホームページを読んだんです
なぜ読んだかというと
漢字は読めなかったんだけど
意味は本物の仏教という
でも
あまり言っちゃうともバレちゃいますからね
場所もちょっと言いにくいんだけど
一応イントロダクションの方で
なぜホームページを作るようになったかというと
自分がいろいろああだこうだとあって
いろいろ仏教についていろいろ不満があったりして
もう東京でも講演でもやりたかったんだと
でも講演やったっても誰一人も来ないんだと
この話し合ってる話し相手だけは来るかもしれませんよと
だからまあそれは意味がないんだと言ったんだ
それでその人は じゃあインターネットでホームページ作ればどうと
それだと世界中みんな読むだろうと
それでもうやっと勉強して
歳も取ってるのに
作ったんだと そこで 本当は息子からいろいろ教えてもらったんだけど
息子に教えてもらうのは悔しいんだから
自分でいろいろ方法を探して勉強したとか
ああだとかこうだとか
ごく普通の日本のお坊さんゆえの話いっぱいあって
本物の仏教 言葉だけ本物であって
内容はもう
初めからもうむちゃくちゃで
誤解じゃなくて
我々はこれを レールを外れていると言うんですよ
初めから乗っている線路が外れているんです
一応  3,000人ぐらいはそのホームページにアクセスした数字がありましたけど
私の数字も入るでしょうと思いますけど
英語でもあるんです 日本語でもあるんです
結局こういうことを言ってるんですね
お釈迦様はもう四十年
五十年間 なんとか言っても
5年間ちょっと日にちずれてるんです
いわゆる大乗仏教の経典の歴史というものがあるんで
中国で決めた歴史なんですけど
その歴史に合うように釈尊の生涯を変えるんですね
釈尊は四十五年間説法していたんだけど
それは歴史的な事実ですけど
それを五十年にしているんです
五十年にするために釈尊は三十歳で悟ったんだと
五年間変えてあげるんです
若くしてあげるんですね
そこまで乱暴なんですね
なぜそこまでアホなことをやるかというと
この大乗仏教の経典を分析した中国の人々が
好き勝手に年代を入れたんですね
華厳は何年間教えた 次のなんとかお経はこれぐらい年間教えた
それから阿含はこのぐらい間説法しましたと
まあ最終的には法華経
法華経はもう十年 二十年間教えたとか
もう自分たち勝手に年代をつけちゃって
その年代に合うように釈尊の生涯を変えてあげると
だから釈尊はその年で生まれて
その年に悟って その年で死ななくちゃいけないんですね
この中国の天台智顗のために
だからそこまでバカバカらしいんですよ
そこで本物の教えは その最後に教えたお経だけですよと
その人々は知らないの
だからお釈迦様 今まで嘘つきやと　と言ってるんですよ
だからずーっとなんかこのひどい便秘状態な感じで
お釈迦様も本物のことを教えられなくて教えられなくて
力んで力んで　もうやっと教えたと
だからそこまでおっしゃったものはもうあまり意味がないということで
それだったら同じ理屈を使うなら
なんで法華経は信じる必要あるんですかと
もしかすると お釈迦様は 100歳まで生きていたならば
他のお教を知るだろうと思いますからね
どうせ信頼できないんだから
そこを反論出ていくと
また何か 言ったりするし
そういうふうな 屁理屈でね
一般人の考え方に沿って喋るだけで
だから 東京で講演やったら一人も聞いてくれないのは当たり前だと思いますよ
物事は合理的に 論理的に喋らなきゃ誰も聞いてくれませんだから
で　そういう風に
人の気持ちに合うように喋るんじゃなくて
お釈迦様は何か真理を教えた
それは我々には難しいかもしれませんし
難しいんだからって勝手に簡単にすると危ないでしょうに
ちょっとわからないなと困ったなというのはわかりますよ
あまりにもわからなくても混乱しましたというならば
それは正直なところそれでいいんです
別に だから簡単に知ろうというのは
象さんのことを知りたいんだと
でもあまりでっかいだから
猫の方がいいと だから猫を勉強して
これは象さんだと思っちゃったら大間違いでしょうに
象さんを触ってみたいんだと
でもでっかくて怖いんだから
じゃあ猫を触ってみると
やっぱり象さんってそんな感じだなと
冗談じゃないでしょうに
触りたいんだけど あまりにもでっかくて怖いんだから触れなかったというならば正直
だから観測は知らないんだと
それは真理 真実を守る人の立場で
猫を触って もうそれで象さんだと勘違いするのも大間違いだからね
ですから このちょっと論理的なことを言ったんだけど
不安の でもそこはもう厳密な 真理であって
仏教の論理的な構造なんですね
それを理解すると 明確にこの宇宙のスケールで不安という現象が理解できるはずなんです
普遍的なスケールで この心にある基準を作る問題と
我々は自分に対しても基準を作る
宇宙に対しても基準を作る
その基準から考える 基準に至るところまでは気持ちいい
基準から出ていくところは認めたくない
いや 苦しみだと思うという事実と
そこで本当の事実はそんな基準があることじゃなくて
物事は変化していく ただそれだけ
それに気持ちいいか気持ち悪いか言う権利も何もない
放っておけばいいということなんですね
心も変化していく 物事も変化していくということは
我々は無常 無常だと口先で言うんだけど
無常というものは 堂々と出会って見てないということなんです
無常に出会ったら 全てはもう問題解決する
そんな難しいことなんでもないんです
本当のところ じゃあこれから 論理を終えて
一般的な我々日常の世界に
一番肝心なのは宇宙はいつ始まるかということではなくて
私はここで私の不安がどう消えるかということだからね
ですから 我々の問題は
不安が生まれるということは
苦しみ生まれることとかね
いつでもまずいろいろ
一番わかりやすいことは
いろんな希望があるんですね
希望の嵐と言ってください
我々人間の人生っていうのは希望の嵐
希望 希望 希望 希望 希望
いっぱい希望があるんです
なぜ希望があるかというと
基準の問題なんですね
ここはこうあればいいと
ここはこうなればいい
ここはこうなれば ああなればこうなればと
いろいろ希望が出てきて
ですから 希望があればあるほど不安が大きくなっちゃうんです
で またそこにすごいややこしいジレンマ的な状態があるんです
希望があると人間が元気で頑張るんですよ
その希望を叶うために
で 希望が消えちゃうとやることがないんだから
なんか暗くて止まってしまっちゃうんですね
何も希望がないということは
すごい暗いイメージの言葉なんですね
希望があると動くんです
希望を実現しようではないかと
で そういう側面もありまして
そこで希望があると この悪い側面っていうのは
希望があるということは
今の自分の状態に不安を持ってるということなんですね
これではダメだと 今の状態ではダメですよと
いわゆる心の中にありますでしょ？あの
変な自分という
尺度になる自分がいるんですね
それを見ると もうちょっとしっかりした方がいいんじゃないかと
この自分が 今の状態でダメですよと
ということから希望が生まれるんです
ですから 希望が一つあるということは
一つ不満があるということ
希望が 2つあるということは
2つ不満があるということ
それでいっぱい希望で溢れて元気で頑張るということは
いっぱい不満で苦しんでいるということにもなるんですね
そこは ジレンマなんです
希望があればあるほど
あなたは今満足していないということでしょ
もっと元気になりたいなというのは
今元気は足りませんということなんですね
もっと痩せたいなと思っちゃうと
今の状態は不安ということでしょう
当たり前でしょうね もっと仕事をバリバリしたいなと思ったら
今の仕事ぶりに対しては不満がある
もっと金入ってほしいなと思ったら
今はもう貧乏性で悩んでいるということなんです
お金が足りませんと
だからどうすればいいんですかね
希望は捨てたらもうなんとなく行動力は消えてしまう
希望があるとすごい苦しみが生まれてくる
そこは問題なんです
どうすればいいんですか？
一応ここで理解してほしいのは
あまりにも希望ありすぎてありすぎてということは
苦しみの塊ということなんです
不安の塊ということなんです
ですから 人がまああなたの夢は何ですか？というと
バンバン言うならば ちょっと心配した方がいいんです
で 子供たちに聞いたら
将来あなた何になりたいなと聞いたら
ある子供はちょっと首をひねっちゃうんですね
何も持ってないんですね
あれはすごい健康なんです
もう心配することないんですよ
あの子はもう自分の子供の人生は思う存分楽しがってるんです
もう将来のことを考える暇がないんです
そこである他の子に聞いたら
こうなりたい ああなりたい言っちゃうでしょ
もう苦しみが始まっているんです
よく見てください 子供
なんか大人から見ればバカに見えちゃうんですよ
なんかあなた将来何になりたい？と聞いたら
首をひねっちゃう ほんと考えたことないんですね
あまりにも聞くと何とか言うんです
子供ってのは大人より頭がいいんだから
なんとか言うんです 子供を大人が楽しくなることをなんとか言うんです
それで大人がすごい楽しがっちゃうんです
たまに子供はこういうことを言う　鳥になりたいとか
そうすると大人がすっごく楽しがっちゃう
やっぱり子供やとかね
かわいいとかね あれ 騙されてるんです
子供はそれぐらい知ってますよ
騙されているし そこに人生哲学もあるんです
本物の哲学 猫になりたいとかね
ああだこうだと言うと
子供の割に　生命は何ですかと見ているんです
自分の命って何ですかと
あれ 言葉ないでしょ ですから直接感じているんですね
だから我々よりは知恵の方が働いているんです
ですから 決してあれは子供の なんとかした譫言みたいなものじゃないんですよ
本当は舞い上がって楽しがるんじゃなくて
真剣にああそうですかと真剣に大人も考えた方がいいと思いますよ
我々にも新しい考え方が生まれてくる
その中から まあとにかく
小さい子供にも聞いたところで
希望 何か夢があるとさっと夢が言ったならば
もうやっぱりその子はもう生きる苦しみがもう始まっているということ
たまに女の子の場合 よくあるんですね
将来どうなるか 看護婦さんにもなりたいし
保母さんにもなりたいし
お母さんになりたいといくつかあるんですよ
あれ ちょっと本当にもう困ったもんなんですね
希望いっぱいあるんだから
大人から見ればもう可愛いと
やっぱり子供らしいやと思って終わるんだけど
そうでもないんです
だからそういう子には もう自分を見てる周りしかいませんだからね
幼稚園の先生ももうかっこよくていいし
お母さんにもなりたいという場合は
お母さんの強い立場を見たら
それもかっこよくて
そうなっていいということもあるし
いろいろ見て これもいいし
これもいいし あれもいいし
これもいいしという という不安なんですね
だからどっちにすればもわからなくなって
全部になりたいと言ってしまっちゃう
それでまだ苦しみが生まれてない子は
ちょっと首を捻ってどうしようかと困っちゃう
何をどんな答えをすればいいかわからないんだから
それもまだまだ心に傷をついてないということで
自分の人生は明るく楽しく思う存分味わっていると
心配ない状態で そこだけは理解しておきましょう
希望があればあるほど
自分の自我層にいっぱい不安を持っている
そこでもう一つジレンマ的なものがあって
例えば希望がありすぎと　希望があると行動するでしょ
それで希望がいくつかあるとさらに行動する
もうちょっとあればさらに行動する
それで希望がたくさんあるとどうなるかというと
行動を何もしないんです
あまりにも希望がありすぎて
どうしようもない状態になっちゃうんです
だからどこから始めた方がわからないでしょうに
だから希望が全くない人も行動しないと仮定すると
希望がいっぱいある人もやりきれなくて行動は停止しちゃうんです
生きる行動 そこで究極的に苦しみを味わっちゃうんです
だから 自分の自画像は完全にもう完璧に自分が不安を感じている
だからいっぱい希望がある
だから自分に対してはものすごく嫌なんです
だからこうなりたい ああなりたい
あれでもない したい これもしたい
こうしたい いっぱいあります
やりたいことはいっぱいあって
一つもできない ですから
希望がありすぎるということは
苦しみがありすぎて もう自己破壊な状態にも陥っているということなんです
だから そこは理解するのは仏教なんです
何か決断して判断することじゃなくて
そういうものだと 生命っていうのは
希望っていうのはあっては困る
なくては困ると
ですから希望あってはいけない
希望ないとそれまた困っちゃうと
そういうことなんです
それは普通の宇宙の法則なんですよ
じゃあ美味しいものを食べてくださいと
だから食べる場合は美味しいものを選んで食べるとどうなるんですか？
早く体壊しちゃうよ
健康を失っちゃいます
だからって食べないでいいんですかね
やっぱり食べなくちゃいけないんですね
体にずっとエネルギーが必要なんです
死んじゃいます
だからと言ってせっかく食べるんだから
美味しく食べるのは当たり前だから
美味しいものを選んじゃうと
全部体に悪いもの よくできてるんですよ
美味しいものは体に悪いようにできているんです
女性の方々 誰でも聞いたら
やっぱりケーキとかよく食べたいでしょうね
たまに レストランなんかで見たっても
でっかいガラスにいろいろソフトクリームやらいろんなものを入れて
すごい高さを喜んで
やっぱり気持ち上がるんで
そういうものは美しくて
もっとスケールが大きくて食べたがっちゃうんですね
でもそんなものを食べちゃうと
いっぱいカロリー入って体の健康をまた失っちゃう
だからケーキ ちょっとしたケーキ食べちゃうと
茶碗一杯のご飯よりすごいカロリーを取ってるんでしょう
だからもっと 他の面で見れば
ケーキ食べるのはもったいないんです
それよりはもう贅沢にご飯を食べた方が体にいいかもしれませんし
でも贅沢にご飯を食べたって
やっぱりケーキ 1つぐらいは食べたいという気持ちはそこにあるんですね
ですから そこを見ても
我々にこの論理見えるんですよ
食べなくちゃいけない
せっかく食べるんだから
美味しく食べようと思ったら
自分の健康は壊してしまうし
だから食べるものっていうのは
あって困る なくて困るものでしょうに
美味しい食事っていうのはあっては困る
なくては困る だからどうすればいいんですかと
じゃあ体にいいんだからといって
あまり美味しくないものは食べたらどうなるかというと
どんどん食欲もなくなっちゃって食べられなくなっちゃうんですよ
全然味もつけないで お塩もかけないで
日本っていうのはものすごい塩好きな文化だから
ですからもう塩もつけないで
野菜とかなんとか食べちゃうと
もうそんな食べられないんですよ
そうすると食欲もなくなっちゃうんですね
そうすると せっかく健康のためにいいものを食べようと思ったところで
もう大事な食欲もなくなってしまったと
その代わりにいっぱいストレスも溜まっちゃって
体壊れたんだという結果になっちゃうんですね
だから世の中のものっていうのは
あって困る なくては困るというものなんですね
そういうディレンマを持たないものは一つもないんです
あるならば教えてください
私も探しているんです
何かあるんですかと あって困らない何かありますかと
すべてのものはそういう風にできているんですね
そこで希望の問題も同じくで
あっては困る なくては困るようなもので
すべてのものはそういうもので
それは落ち着いて理解しましょう
ああだこうだではなくて
そこで希望の問題の場合は
まずこれ言いたいんです
希望いっぱいあって それで落ち込んで何も活動できなくなって
徹底的なうつ病になっちゃったりして
このうつ病の人を見てください
本人は言わないんだけど
心ちょっと掘ってみると
出るわ出るわ ありとあらゆる希望
あまりにも希望を入れて入れて入れて入れて
最終結果はうつ病
部屋からも出ない 行動はできない
だから あまりにも欲なんですね
ですから この自分 我々はちょっと希望が増えると気をつけた方がいいんです
希望が増えるとどうしますかというと
丁寧に 私はいつでも 嫌味を言われる存在ですけど
失礼だ 失礼なことばっかり言ってるんだとか
まあなんて言いますか
叱られてるんだとかよく言われるんです
言われるんだけど それはしょうがないんだけど
私は全然びくともしないんだから大丈夫ですけど
私の失礼な質問を皆様自分に聞いてください
私の希望は何ですか？と
まず具体的にリストアップすることなんです
リストアップして 自分の部屋にでも大きな文字で書いておいてください
正直に全ての希望 どんな汚い希望でもいいんです
全部正直に書いてみてください
そうでないと実現できませんから
物事が具体的にならないと
本当に自分がどうなりたいかと
思い浮かぶものは何でも書く
こういうふうになりたい
ああいうふうになりたいと
あるでしょ？例えば立派な歌は誰が歌っていると
ああいう風に歌いたいなと
そうするとさっさとそれ書いてください
何々さんと同じく歌えるようになればいいと
すごい 美しい人が映画やらテレビやら出てたら
すごいかっこいいなと
あのプロポーションなんか抜群にいいなとかね
じゃあ書いてください
なんとか人のように なんとかモデルさんのように私も美しくなりたいとかね
そういうふうに全部人に知られても良いものも
知られたら困るものも
自分にさえ知られて
恥ずかしいものでも
何でもまずリストアップすることなんですよ
それでリスト作って 2日3日経ったところで
人のもののような感じで読んでみる
自分のものじゃない感じで読んでみると
何のこともなく見えるんですよ
このくだらない どうでもいい希望は全部
それで全部削除する こんなことはありえないんだとね
例えば自分の年は 50歳で
なんとか なんとか 有名な いるんですね
モデルさんとかね
その人と同じ 彼らも ありっこはないと言うことやと思う
そんなことやめましょうとかね
そういう風に どうでもいい希望は全部消せる
大体 70%  80%ぐらい
そういう風に消えちゃうんです
消えちゃったらもう 20%ぐらい残るかも知れませんよ
我々の希望の中で それでそんなものはきれいさっぱり心から消しちゃったら
いかに楽になるかと ただそれだけで
それから残り 20%にどうしますかというと
また例えば 億万長者になりたい
金持ちになりたいんだと言ったら
お金が必要ということは常識であって
別に非合理的なものじゃないんですね
人間には生活するためにお金が欲しいんだと
お金が欲しいんだけど
今更自分に億万長者になれるかどうかといえば
もう なれっこは無いかもしれません
だからまあそれはやめましょうと
例えば 世界旅行したいと希望があったと
できるかなと思ったら
もしかするとできるかもしれない
もしかするともう絶対自分の状況ではできないかもしれません
それぞれ人の状況は違いますからね
家は全く離れない人もいるし
いろいろ条件があって
あるいは家は離れたってもいいんだけど
仕事のことで全くそんな暇がない人もいるし
暇があっても全然 世界旅行するために収入がないかもしれませんし
これからも出ないかもしれません
貯金もないかもしれませんし
あるいは世界旅行したいんだけど
自分の体がいろいろ問題があって
世界旅行するためにはもうふさわしくないかもしれません
そういうことをわかりますから
じゃあこれもカットと
それもカットしていく
そうすると ほんのわずかな希望が残るんです
残る希望は全部実現できるものなんです
頑張れば 実現できるならば
まあウジウジしないで頑張ってみると
それでその希望は実現できる
このごちゃ混ぜにして混乱だらけで
ただ不安 不安だけではもう何もやれないんです
だから希望あるってことも不安だからね
それ不安から全部出てくるんだから
ですから 不安 不安といい加減なことを言ってはいけないんです
不安を作ったのは前に説明したもので
それから現実の世界で自分に対して不安があって
自分っていうのは
自画像ですね
自画像に対していろいろ不安があって
希望を作っちゃう その希望
またくだらなくて 非合理的でどうでもいい
どんな希望あるか自分でもわからなくなっちゃって
落ち込んだり うつ病になったり
いろんなことを大変なことになったりする
その場合は 仏教的な解決方法ではなくて
ごく普通の心理学的な解決方法なんです
希望はリストアップして
もうくだらないものは全部削除してカットして
その中で具体的に実現できるものだけ選んで
私の希望はこれだけだと
あんなものは馬鹿らしい考え方だけで
それを楽しみに考えただけですよと
思って楽になって それを実現しようと頑張る
努力する それは確実に得られる
問題ないんです 例えば 5 キロぐらい痩せればいいなと思ったら
それは別に非合理的なものじゃないでしょうに
悪いことでもないでしょうに
それでも自分に対する不安なんですけど
でも 5 キロぐらいだったら じゃあ頑張ってみると
頑張れば得られるんだから
テレビでオーストラリアの人の番組見てたんですよ
男で こんなでっかい体で 300 キロかな
ものすごい覚えてないんだけど
で  1 年以内で 100 キロにしたんですよ
頑張って で それはどのように頑張ったかと
その過程を見せたんだけど
やっぱりその男は決めちゃったんです
俺も全然モテないし
若いし でも仕事上よく食べるみたい
シェフやっていて
だから　なんて言いますか
料理を作るところに行くと
全く迷惑で みんなに 彼がチーフですから
いなくちゃいけないんだけど
一人で動かないんですね
ものすごいでっかい体で
そこでもう全部肉も魚ももう綺麗にやめちゃったりして
食べ物はもうやめ
それは仕事上食べなくちゃいけないんだから
考えて食べてはいけないんだと
でも味見しなくちゃだから
ただ味を見るだけ 食べないと
それぐらい自分をコントロールして
それでとことん丁寧に運動をいろいろしたりして
泳いだりとかね それで
でもお腹が少なくならない
小さくならない でもどんどん小さくなったんだけど
お腹がもうタランと でお医者さんに行っちゃったら
あなたはまだ体重が多いんだから手術できないんだと
で  100 ぐらいになったところで
余計なところは全部取っちゃったら
ピッタリスマートの立派な男になったんです
だからあれぐらいの体重でもね
決まったら得られるもんなんですよ
だからその人にとっては余計なことなかったんです
もう一人の友達とちょっと掛け合っただけなんです
じゃあ頑張って お互い様
頑張ってみようと 友達の方が ほんのちょっと体重を減らせばよかったんですね
この人はもう 200 減らさなくちゃいけないんです
あの人は 五十ぐらいかなと
で 彼が怠けちゃったんです
で 彼の体重はそのままで
この人はもうぴったしスマートになった
そういうことで それでこの後の状態が楽しくて
相手の女の友達もできちゃって
それで今まで部屋の中で食べるばっかしの人生はいかに暗かったかと
外で遊んだり バイクに乗ってあっちこっち行ったりとかね
そういうのをどれほど楽しいかとわかったところで
もうそれからもその性格を続けているんだと
ですから幸福でしょうに
だから希望はいっぱいあったんじゃなくて
一つあった それ一つぐらいはなんとかできると
考えちゃうと なんか想像できないほどのことなんでしょうね
これはいろんなこんがらがってる希望で考えちゃうと
スマートになりたいし
でもお腹が空いてるし
美味しいものを食べたいし
ああだこうだあっちゃうと
実行できないんですね
そこで彼が美味しいものを食べたい
まあそれはカットと
動きたくない 部屋でテレビ見たいとか
それはダメと そういう余計な希望は全部ちゃんと削除して
いや スマートになりたい
それだけで終わる 一つの希望で成功しちゃうんですね
ですから 希望いっぱいあるということは
不安そのものであって
苦しみそのものであって
行動はなくなっちゃう
ですから 希望少なくじゃなくて
希望はできるだけ少なく
その方が楽なんです そこであのディレンマのことを言ったんですね
希望は全く消えちゃったら行動が消えるんだろうと
それはこの自画像ある愚か者に対してなんですよ
いわゆる悟ってない普通の人間にとっては自画像があって
それで問題を作ってるでしょ
自画像があるんだから
それに添えて希望もないということは
もう最低に暗いんです
仏教というのは自画像を作ったことは間違ってるよと
無常だから流れてずっと流れているんだから
どっちが基準かっていうのは一つもないんだと
まあもう話に戻りますけど
例えば人間の人生の中で
80歳まで生きている人の人生の中で
何歳は本当の中心ですかね
本当の人生って何歳ですかね
そんな年ないんでしょう
生まれた0歳の時でも人生であって
1歳の時でも人生であって
3歳 5歳 10歳　25歳の時でも人生であって
40歳 60歳 80歳になる時でも 人生そのものなんですよ
基準にするところは何一つもないんです
だから我々 そもそも間違っているんであって
だから基準を作っちゃえば
それはもう不安の元であって
それから苦しみが生まれてくるんであって
ですから そういう基準ある人が
自画像ある人にとっては
希望が消えちゃったらもうとことん暗い
もう何もやることがなくなっちゃって
暗くなる   でも違う道もあります
基準はない 今の自分の人生はもう完璧な人生だと
今 1日は自分の命の一番大事な 1日だと
1日を重ねて全て人生だからね
この人生っていうのはただの頭の妄想概念であって
頭で計算して出てくる
それは数学的な問題であって
数学というのは 正真正銘の頭の遊びだから
私の人生はっていうのは単なる頭の妄想概念であって
生きているのは 1日  1日生きているんだから
2 日間 2 日間生きてる人がいるんですかね
生きているのは 1 日だけ
1日の中でももう今だけで
ですから 今のだけでやれることをやりますと
ベストを尽くしますと
今の時間に 希望はそこでなくなっちゃう
全く全部 明日のこれはもう置いておきましょう
明日のこと とにかく生きているのは今ですから
明日ってのは頭の妄想概念だから
だから今の時間で私はベストを尽くしますと
今の時間に何もしないでボケーとするのは気持ち悪いんだと
だからベストを尽くしますと
今だけベストを尽くす
それはとっても簡単なんです
今 自分のベストを尽くす人には希望はなし
大胆な希望は何もなし
でも充実して生活もできる
失敗もなし ベストを尽くしているんだから
失敗というのは比べたら出てくるもので
充実感もあるし ものすごい行動的でもあるし
明るいし 悩むヒマがないんだから
悩んじゃったら損でしょうに
今の瞬間ですから 人生は悩むこともない
そうすればすぐに明るいんです
ですから 希望を全部失って
失ってではなくて 希望一つも成り立たない
それでももう十分明るく
ものすごい行動的で元気で活動する道は
その道なんです 今という瞬間に自分を絞る
今元気であればいいと
今ベストを尽くせばいいと
明日のことはもう妄想概念だと
それは私のなんて言いますか
仕事範囲 コントロールの範囲じゃないんだと
IT is not under my control と言えば
日本語になるとどうなるんですか
いや 明日はね  Tomorrow is not under my control
明日は私のコントロールできるものじゃないんですよと
でも 今ということは 完全に under my control I can control
私にコントロールできます
今だけだったら そうすると完全たる支配者で
自分の支配下で立派に生きていられるんです
まあ それはこの仏教から見て
完全に不安をなくす方法なんです
それから我々またすごい不安があることがありまして
この病気ということ
家庭は安定しているわ
収入は安定しているわとかね
そこらへん問題ないんだけど
体のことは心配と　というふうなこともあります
結構病気なことで不安がある
不安があるという人は
具体的に私にも話を聞いてくることもあるし
病気が不安だと
それ前に言いたいのは
この心と体っていうのはもう一緒に行動してるんです
体っていうのは機械で
この機械動くエネルギーは心で
と そう思ってください
で 細胞でできているんだけど
この細胞一つ一つの中に命として活動しているのは心なんですね
そこで心は病気になったと
不安だらけですよと というとどうなるんですかね
体はもう完全に壊れてしまいます
体中 我々の心が入っていて行動しています
その心がもう完璧に病気になっちゃって
不安だらけで落ち着きがなくて
悩み苦しみだけで 余計な希望ばっかしで
希望があればあるほど苦しみが増える
増えるわ 行動はできなくなっちゃうわ
そうすると体健康的になるんですかね
すぐ体が病気になるんです
この細菌のせいで病気になると言っても
それはそんなに恐ろしい問題じゃないんですよ
これ たまたまなんですよ
私にももう細菌が入っちゃって
風邪引いても 3週間目になっているんですけど
でも大体そんなに病気になったことは見てないでしょうに
そうなったって 僕は全部自分のやりたいことは全部やってるんだから
やらなくちゃいけないことは
昨日とか一昨日か もう本当に声が出ないほど
もう声が仲悪くなっていたんだけど
でもそれでも自分のやらなくちゃいけないことはやれるし
これはちょっとここら辺はちょっとね
微生物が頑張ってるだけのことで
勝手にしろと そちらにはという感じで
ですから 心さえ元気であれば
そんなに問題ないんですね
薬飲む必要ない そのうち治るだろうと放っておいているんです
当然そのうち治りますからね
もう別に問題ないんです
今も一応治っている状態ですけど
まあ壊れたものはまた出来上がるまでは時間かかる
もうこういう細胞なんか壊れてるんだから
新しい細胞が出来上がるまではちょっと時間かかる
それだけのことですけど
このウイルスやら細菌やら
そういうもので病気になるというのは
で そんな大変な問題ではないんです
一番大変な問題っていうのは
心で病気 例えば風邪引いたんだから
ああ どうしよう 風邪引いちゃった
大変だ ああだこうだと　心で悩むことなんですね
それで心で悩む人は風邪にこれはいい
じゃあこれも飲みます
これはいい これも飲みます
あれはいい あれも飲みます
これ片っ端から薬飲んでお腹が壊して新しい病気が出てくるんですよ
私は風邪引いちゃったらもういろいろもう飲まない食べない
なぜならば当然体が弱くなってるんだから
体にいいとおかゆを飲んだり
また何か飲んだり また何か食べたり
またなんて冗談じゃないんです
でも結構みんなやっちゃうんです
本当は病気になって体が弱い状態にあるんだから
体に優しく もうあまりいじめないでおいた方がいいのに
いろんな薬を探して探して飲むわ
薬自体は強烈でしょうね
それでまあ病気にピッタリ合う薬だったらいくら強烈でもしょうがないんだけど
それでまた他のものを試してみるわ
他のものも試してみるわ
それは心はもう落ち着いてないんだからなんです
それだけじゃなくて この体を動かしているエネルギーは心だから
この心汚れたら 心に不安があったら
身体的にもありとあらゆる症状が出てきます
それは お医者さんもほとんどわからない
人間というのはみんな不安を持ってるんだから
あまり気にしない ただ
あなたの腸が悪いですか？胃が悪いんですか？とかね
そこら辺に薬入れたりする
薬入れたっても 病気なのは心だから
ただ弱くなってる 胃がさらに弱くなるだけ
だからキリがないんです
お医者さんにとっては商売繁盛していいんですけど
肝心な人間にとっては苦しみには終わりがないんですよ
血圧の問題も血管の問題も
もうどんな病気にしても
90%以上全部心から生まれるんです
大体経験あるでしょ 例えばすごい心配事があると食欲がなくなっちゃう
何か大変ショックを受けちゃったら
もう食べられない 寝られないと
普段食べるのはもう当たり前であって
食べることは楽しみに生きてる
やってる人がちょっとショックを受けちゃったら
もう食べられなくなるでしょう
すぐ心の状態 体に効く
例えばすごい元気な男の人に
男性の人にでも何か自信のない仕事をさせてみてください
あとはこちらの仏教の話はよく聞いてらっしゃる方々ですけど
いきなり一人を選んで
あなたこっち来て 喋ってくださいと言っちゃったら喋れると思いますか？いくら立派な男性であろうが
体がガタガタしちゃう
いきなり言われたら そう言われるならば
前もって言って頼んで
その人もそれなりの準備をして
心をちゃんと用意して大丈夫だと来ないと
足も手も震えるんです
声が出なくなっちゃうんです
別に体力に問題あるわけじゃないんです
その時もすぐ心の状態が体に移っちゃうでしょうに
ですから 心は甘く見てはいけないんです
心はなめてはいけないんです
体ばっかりいじって健康になりたい
健康になりたいと そんなものは忘れてもいいんですよ
運転さんがすごい上手であれば
どんなボロ車でも立派に運転しますよ
問題ないんです 車に文句を言うのは運転下手な人なんです
自分乗ってる車に
運転に自信がある人は
ちょっとブレーキ効かないなとわかっても
あ この車ちょっとブレーキが効かないんだと
それだったら安全運転だったらこういう風にやった方がいいやと
すぐ計算に入っちゃうんです
例えば車のテールライトですか
後ろにありますね 信号出すあれないと
ボロ車だったらもう全部機能するわけじゃないんだから
それは運転不安な人だったら運転できないんですよ
でもすごい自信がある人は
あ それで大丈夫ですと
こういう風に運転すれば
このチカチカと後ろの光の信号がなくても
大丈夫なような状態に運転を変える
運転のやり方
ですから 体いじるよりは心を直せば病気はいろいろ結構治ります
それはもう科学的な事実であって
ですから 我々不安な心で悩んでいるならば
我々自分の心も壊しているということなんです
健康も壊している すべての幸福を壊しているんですよ
人間にとっては 財産というのは健康な体ですよと
いわゆる ラーバっていうのは徳ですね
一番高徳　一番高い
一番優れている徳は 損得の徳は健康ですよとお釈迦様おっしゃってるんです
パーリ語で覚えてください
この前も書いた覚えがあります
アーロギャ・パラマー・ラーバー
アーロギャ 健康であること
パラマー 最高たる徳である
ですから お釈迦様はもうちゃんと合理的に具体的におっしゃってますよ
涅槃涅槃ばっかりじゃないんです
健康でなければ何もできませんだから
瞑想もできませんし 生きていたっても何の面白くも何もないし
病弱だったら
だから全ての楽しみなくなっちゃうでしょ
健康なくなっちゃったら
それは心が弱くて不安ばっかしだったら
希望ばっかしで そうすると心はひどい目に遭います
体もひどい目に遭います
ですから 自分の将来に対して
将来は病気になるかなと心配だなというふうな心配は要りませんね
結局は そういう心配あるならばもう大丈夫なんです
例えば 私はすごく不安があるんだと聞いたら
僕は聞いたところで ある人々に別に他のことではなくて
自分の体のこと 病気のことを心配ですよと
ただ その時はそんな答えしなかったんだけど
今は言いますけど それだったら僕に言えるのは
それだったら大丈夫ですと
あなたは確実に病気になりますと
他の人より早く それもなったところで
もうひどいもんで治らないんです
慢性になっちゃうと それはそうなるんです
病気になったらどうしようか
病気になったらどうしようかと心配やったら
この心が痛み傷んでいるんだから
不安で 体がその通りに希望通りに病気になっちゃうんですね
で 治らない
ですから 将来に病気になりたくないと思うならば
そんなことは考えないこと
将来のことは放っておくこと
今 明るく元気で 明るい心で
そんな心配はしませんと
という生き方で生きていなくちゃいけないんです
日本でもたまにテレビで見せますけど
長寿の人々のことを見せたりする
テレビでは長寿の食べ物とかね
そんなこと言うんだけど
そんなもん全くもう無意味なバカバカらしいことで
そんなものを食べても長寿できるわけじゃないんだけど
その人々の生き方 人生論を言ってほしいんですよ
その場合は かなり長寿の人々は何も病気はない
歯がある 自分の歯で食べているし
朝から晩まで仕事をするし
もう 100歳であろうと
もう何のことなく もう全く不安がない
家のことであろうが 仕事のことであろうが
明日のことであろうが
その人は全く不安がなくて
この 1 日だけ元気で生きて食べて
よく寝て生活しているんですよ
だからずっと元気なまんまで続いているんです
心痛んでないんだから
ですから 病気に対して不安がある人々にとっては
一番まずやらなくちゃいけないことは
もう今大丈夫でしょうとということで
明るく今元気で生きていられれば
それで満足することなんです
明日のことは明日に放っておくことなんです
だから 病気になったら
その時その時ですよと
それはその時ですよと
今から風邪薬やら胃薬やら集めていても
お腹壊しちゃうとこの薬はもう時間切れでしょうに
お腹を壊したら　胃の薬買って飲むんであって
誰の家を見ても薬の箱まであるんですよ
そこで病気になったところで箱を開けてみたら
全部もう時間切れてるんですね
それよりはもう熱が出たらすぐもう薬屋さんに走って
その場で薬買ったら 今できたばっかしの薬飲めるんだから
で 僕は薬なんかちょっとしたことで薬買う場合も
店の人言うんです
90もあります
30もありますけどとかね
私はそう考えるのは これは 1 日何回飲みますか？と
だからこれは 1 日 3つ飲みますよ
で 僕計算する 私の病気はだいたい今日飲んで明日飲んだら治ると
ですから 私に必要なのは 6つですね
と思っちゃうんですね
でも日本では 6つは買えないんですね
贅沢な国だから
そこで 60 は要りませんと
60錠 じゃあ 30 もっと少ない量はないんですか？と聞くんです
そしたら もう大体30錠とかね
それぐらい あるいは 15 とかありますけど
15 買っても僕はすごく悔しいんです
お金はもったいなくなったと
なぜならば 2日で治りますから
6つしか要りませんでしょ
残りのものはどうします？ちゃんとしまっておく
普通だったらね 私もみんなに聞かれるんだから
もうしまっておくんだけど
もうまた同じ病気になってみると
もう時間経ってるんですよ
あれは そこでバカみたいに 60錠ぐらい買っちゃったらどうなるんですかね
自分の国だったらすごく大丈夫
その点でうちら稼いでおるんです
みんなにお金ないんですよ
たくさん買うお金が ですから
1 日分  2 日分しか買わないんです
で そこで無駄もないし
古くなった薬飲むことにもならないんです
で やっぱりこういう国が発展するとね
ちゃんともうパッケージ作って瓶に入れて
それをやっぱり 6,000円で 5,000円で売らなきゃ商売にならないし
ですから 大事な薬を買って無駄にゴミ箱に捨てる
結局ゴミ箱に捨てるために買ってるんですよ
すごい大事な薬 で 薬なくて人々は病気で死んでしまっちゃうし
他の国々で ここで薬買ってゴミ箱に薬買って
ゴミ箱に薬買ってゴミ箱に
それで治療費はすごく高いんだと
で いろいろ問題もあるし
そういうのを直せばもうすぐ治るもんなんですよ
薬は 1 日分  2 日分だけ買えばいいし
そういうシステム作ればいいし
この威張ることやめればいいんです
とにかく
体の病気に対する余計な不安をやめちゃって
もし病気になったら その場ですぐ行動すればいいんです
ちょっと病気になったら　大量に薬買うなと
大量に薬買うことはものすごい心配性ということなんですね
今治ってもまた病気になったらどうするの？と私に言われたことありますよ
皆様から それ要りませんと
そんなたくさん いえ そんなこと言わないでも
また病気になったらどうするんですか？私はそうなりませんから
それはそちらの問題だから
だからそこら辺なんです
問題は 薬を例えば 8錠飲んだところで治るし
そうするともう 60錠買っておく
念のために あの念のためにということは問題なんです
そこは問題の種になる
念のためにということで
ものすごく不幸になって
病気で病気で病気で不幸になってしまっちゃうんです
念入り要りません 念というのは仏教用語でサティですけどね
これサティは必要ですけど
こういうくだらない念入りは要りません
例えば足を折ったならば
キャストをすぐ入れたならば
まずなんとかというね
必要ですけど 今から買っておく必要ありますかね
念のために足を折ったらということで
今からもうまつえ　何て言いますか？それは
松葉杖も買っておく必要ないでしょう
でもそういうことをやってる
そういう似ていることをやってる
そういうことで話は終了しますけど
そういうふうな人間にいろいろ不安というものからありとあらゆる問題が生まれるし
それはもう簡単に解決する方法もあるということで話を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます